أشعر أننا نفرط في استخدام موارد
كوكبنا ، فنحن نريد توسيع
إمكانيات الزراعة في
بيئة لم تكن كذلك ، لكن
يمكنك بالفعل زراعة نباتات نعتقد
أنها يمكن أن تغير النظرة
المستقبلية للمستقبل
[موسيقى]
حديقة نيمو  هو
مشروع زراعي بديل حيث
نحاول إيجاد طريقة لزراعة النباتات تحت
الماء في البيوت الزجاجية تحت الماء ، قمنا بزراعة ما
بين 50 إلى 60 نوعًا
مختلفًا من الريحان أنواعًا مختلفة من السلطات ، غوجي
براعم الصويا ، الأعشاب الطبية ،
حصاد النباتات في الواقع أمر بسيط للغاية ، لقد قمنا
بقطعه  تمامًا كما نفعل على الأرض
ثم نلفها في حاويات بلاستيكية قابلة لإعادة الاستخدام
ونغلقها فقط
ونلتقطها على السطح بشكل لطيف ومريح ،
فإن التحديات الرئيسية
لنمو النباتات تحت الماء لم يتم تنفيذها أبدًا ،
إنها جديدة تمامًا في البداية
كان منحنى التعلم شديد الانحدار للغاية ،
حيث يجب إجراء كل عملية الغوص تحت الماء
الذي يمثل تحديًا بحد ذاته ،
والمزايا الرئيسية هي الحماية من
الخارج  عناصر بيئة تطوير متكاملة
نحن تحت الماء لا شيء يمكن أن يصل إلينا ،
لا توجد آفات تعني عدم الحاجة إلى مواد كيميائية
وبالطبع لا يوجد برد ولا عواصف ،
استقرار درجة الحرارة
الموجود داخل الماء وهو أكثر
استقرارًا من الخارج بالإضافة إلى أن
الضغط العالي تحت الماء يجعل
نباتاتنا تنمو على ما يبدو  أسرع وأقوى ومع وجود
محتويات أعلى من الزيوت الأساسية ، فإن
الماء الذي نستخدمه للنباتات يكون في
الغالب من تبخر
سطح الماء المالح بمجرد
تبخره يتكثف مرة أخرى في المطر ، فنحن ننتج
مياه عذبة بشكل تلقائي
لا نحتاج إلى ذلك  تستهلك أي
طاقة لأننا نعلم أن تغير المناخ
ومستقبل الديموغرافيا يتجهان
نحو طريقة سنفرط
فيها في استخدام موارد كوكبنا
وآمل أن تكون حديقة Nemo وسيلة لاستخدام
هذه الموارد بطريقة محترمة للغاية
وبطريقة متوازنة
تتمثل الثقافة الكاملة للمشروع في توسيع
إمكانيات الزراعة في
عالم مغطى بأكثر من 70 ٪ من المياه ،
فهو ببساطة يجعله منطقيًا  ه لنا
لك